Now, let's talk a little bit
more about registration and
especially what to do when
a class you want is full.
So here I've looked
up a different class.
An intro to cognitive science class, but
what I find is that this class is full.
I know it's full for
two different reasons.
First, over on the left there is a C.
C means closed.
That means
there's no spots left in this class.
Secondly, there are three columns over
on the right that represent the current
enrollment in the class.
The columns are CAP, ACT, and REM.
CAP represents
the capacity of the class.
ACT represents the number of active
students currently registered for
the class.
And REM represents the remaining
slots in the class.
For this class I know it's full,
because it has zero remaining slots.
When that happens, what I have to do
is join the wait list for the class.
There are three similar columns that
represent the status of the wait list,
WL Cap, WL Act, and WL rem.
Just like the columns for regular
registration, WL Cap, WL Act, and
WL rem, represent the capacity,
the active number of students, and
the remaining slots.
Specifically, on the wait list.
So, if I want to join a full class,
I have to join the wait list.
To join the wait list,
I have to use the second of the two
registration methods we talked about.
First, I have to note
the class' CRN number.
In this case it's 55110.
And then I have to return to
the Add/Drop Classes page.
Usually, I would do that through the
registration menu, but between you and
me, you can actually get to it just by
clicking Add to WorkSheet, whether or
not you have anything selected.
That will take you back to
the Add/Drop Classes page.
Scrolling down,
we want to go back to CRN section.
You want to enter the five digit CRN
number that you noted before and
again, click submit changes.
Now here what's going to happen is
you're going to be given an error like
we talked about.
Under registration add errors,
you'll see closed as the status
of your registration.
Under the action menu,
you can click Wait listed course.
Click submit changes again.
And the course will now
appear as a waitlisted course
under your current schedule.
In the event that a slot in
the waitlisted course becomes available,
you'll receive an email and you can
return to this page and register for
the course the way we did before.
You only have a limited window of time
to register for the course however, so
make sure to do so as soon as possible.
For more information on how long you
have to register once you receive that
email, check the registrar's website,
that can change from
semester to semester.